all righty let's go ahead and get get
this show on the road does everyone have
one of these awesome I included some
just an outline and space for you to
take some notes if you wanted to if you
don't like to take your notes that way
you can just rip it off and throw it
away try not to rip it off and throw
away all the other stuff because you
know I worked on that and that would be
me at least do it when I'm not looking
but I will every every one of those
pages will hopefully get at least a
little bit of an explanation so yeah
maybe maybe you keep them around for a
while
welcome I am John Gregg I know most of
you those of you don't know me yeah you
all know me the yeah you guys are very
bold to sign up for a math talk right
after lunch those of you who will fall
asleep it's very bold of you a very bold
of you but and it's a very sexy topic on
memorizing math facts so that will at
least keep my salah entertained
now as i was writing these abstracts you
know first of all it's very difficult to
write an abstract on how to make math
facts you know it's popping music you
know so I realized that hey I'm a nerd
and B no one is gonna come to this talk
but here you all are so that's that's
fantastic
do you get one of these so math facts is
our topic today hopefully this will be
both a chance to to think a little bit
about why it matters which i think is a
lesser sort of problem I think we all
understand why it matters but I think
why it matters has something to say
about how we do it but then really the
the big question in our room is how do
we get our kids to memorize their math
facts
and and what are some creative practical
new ways of doing that that I can take
back to my classroom so hopefully we're
gonna spend the majority of our time on
today and hopefully you can take away at
least something of what I've done a lot
of this is hopefully bits and pieces
that if you don't want to just say I'm
gonna do exactly what mr. Gregg told me
to do you can take some of the pieces
and incorporate them into your classroom
as well so they hopefully there'll be
some good ideas but let's let's let's
start with the problem and actually I
think the problem is worth talking about
here especially in this room because
oftentimes you don't see the problem
with not memorizing your math facts
until you get into fourth grade or fifth
grade or sixth grade and I actually want
to I want to I want to walk through this
problem right here okay I want to do
this not a not a kindergarten 1st or 2nd
grade problem none of you will do this
this is a fifth grade problem right so
but I want to watch it happen
if you don't know your math facts okay
which means we have to count on our
fingers for every arithmetic process
okay so 2 times 8 2 4 6 8 10 12 14 16
great 7 times 8 7 14 21 28 35 42 49 56
plus 1 d7
6 times 8 6 12 18 24 30 36 42 48 plus 5
49 50 51 52 t30 2 times 3 2 4 6 7 times
3 7 14 anyone 6 times 3 6 8 6 12 18 19
20 sake plus 0 7 plus 6 13 1 plus 3 1 2
3 4 plus 1 i plus 0 and 2 you get our
answer 21500 36 and there's our answer
but it took us a good amount of time do
you notice how many operations there
were in a single problem like that
pretend you're a fifth grader and you
just did that to solve that problem do
you feel exhausted tired defeated yeah
do you hate math yeah you do right
you absolutely do right do you are you
interested at all in learning about any
of the any of the cool ways in which you
could potentially do this a little bit
easier or the kind of how that would
work in a word problem or are you
interested at all in any of those kind
of things you're not right it's because
actual the actual arithmetic
calculations are so difficult right I
think I wrote down this requires six
multiplication facts and I think there's
11 addition facts in there but there's
probably more so exactly yeah lots of
room for error if you're counting on
your fingers right any one of those and
I did that pretty quick cuz I'm pretty
good at knowing my sixes right the kids
who the kids who are doing that they
don't know that right it's exactly right
so it takes them even longer
to do that right the other problem I was
gonna do for you long division problem
right that's actually the worst one I
wrote down
there's at least three division problems
three subtraction problems three
multiplication problems and each of
those division problems requires them to
checks you know when you're at saying
how many times does 6 go into 59
they're not gonna know that off the top
of their head so they're gonna have to
you know so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
put you through that because it's
painful but I think it's important for
us that it's converted the first of the
second grade teachers sitting here to
have that vision for what happens to
those students because once they get to
fourth and fifth grade this is the
that's it's painful and this is where
you get kids who say I hate math never
gonna do it and once you get a couple of
kids like that in your fifth grade class
you kind of get a lot of kids like that
in your fifth grade class because that
spreads pretty quickly it spreads pretty
quickly so the problem actually the real
problem doesn't show up in kindergarten
first and second grade but the solution
happens in kindergarten first and second
grade and so but that's the real
difficult problem with teaching Kinneret
for surgeries you have to put the time
and the investment in for the kids
future now for their present necessarily
when you're adding 7 plus 6 and your
kids are doing it on their fingers they
can get 13 in a matter of a few seconds
and they can get it right all right what
happens is this right and so us
intervene on the front lines of make
sure that doesn't happen okay so we're
gonna talk about how that doesn't happen
that's actually not the real problem
here this is the symptoms of the problem
right this is what we're noticing in our
students okay but what is the real
problem your problem is twofold first
the real problem is that thing you're
counting is an absolutely acceptable and
ideal way to introduce your students to
topics okay that is when I'm teaching my
kids about addition
I'm gonna teach them about addition
using the counting on my fingers and we
you all do that and I hope you do that
right or at least maybe not counting on
your fingers but counting upwards right
if you're doing eight plus three at the
very beginning all right you want to do
eight nine ten eleven that's exactly how
kindergartners or first graders should
encounter addition and when you're doing
if your second-grade teacher that's
maybe a little bit high for a
second-grade you getting three times
four
right they should experience it three
six nine twelve because that's what
that's what addition is multiplication
is so the problem here right problem one
if you're counting or just counting
really is the right way to introduce
arithmetic it absolutely is
I'm not saying never count on your
fingers all right if you're when you're
teaching kids or I'm never count upwards
and backwards all right if you're doing
52 minus four very first way I'll do
that 51 50 49 48 okay the second part of
the problem is this finger counting
is super reliable all right and that
kids get the right answer by counting on
their fingers almost every time it's
great we have 10 fingers it works really
well
all right kids it's successful right you
can you can do 9 plus 5 on your fingers
all day right and any you can actually
get the right answer
it's very because you can look at the
end and say I added those five and I got
214 right and so what happens is that
kids rely on it right they if it's the
right way to be introduced to it and if
it's a good if it's successful you rely
on it and you make that the thing that
now you're starting to do some you're
trying to do something new with your
students you're trying to introduce them
to other ways of doing this the same
problem and they say oh finger counting
is always always works for me I do it
this way
right and I this way I can get the right
answer on my fingers you try to make a
transition but they're so ingrained in
their habits right that's actually very
difficult to make a transition so what I
want to talk about today is that
transition moments right and I think
this is the second section on your yes
what do we need okay great what do we
eat is a transition okay let me make
sure Elmo knows okay good so yeah so any
transition - in transition tradition
from from finger counting transition to
finger counting use your plate be
replaced by two things okay
your account needs to be replaced by a
place value right I'm not gonna talk so
much you go please failure today right
you guys probably heard place failure a
ton and I'm not gonna talk about that
too much okay and B what I'm gonna call
a factual fluency okay so and you can't
that here's the here's the real problem
right only the combination of those two
things can possibly replace the finger
counting only the combination of these
so what I mean is this and let me show
you how this works because right these
words don't really mean anything unless
you actually know what they know what I
mean by them so what I mean by that is
this if we take this problem 59 plus 23
okay I can do that counting down my
fingers 60 61 seriously is there a sec
yadda yadda yadda yadda yeah it right I
can't and I can't even make myself do
that
I swore as I was going to this talk that
I would I would actually count all the
way from 59 who's you 9 to 82 I can't do
it I just can't bring myself to do it ok
so I failed yeah okay so I failed that
but 59 plus 23 you can get it by
counting on your fingers right and some
soon as well but the replacement is this
all right and you can watch this happen
right
nine ones plus three runs this twelve
ones two ones and change the ten ones
into 110 110 plus five tens is six tens
plus two 10s is eight tens I have eight
tens and two ones which is 82 right okay
so it this is the replacement for finger
counting let me just do one more example
cuz I think I wrote it down on my sheet
15 times five
all right just so you can hear it again
50 times five right you can do it
counting on your fingers and I'm
actually gonna do this 15 30 45 60 75
all right or you can do it five groups
of five ones it's 25 ones which leaves
me with five ones and take the 20 ones
and convert them into two tens five
groups of one ten is five tens plus the
other two tens that I have is seven tens
seven tens and five
is 75 okay so we've got the place value
but so so what happened there was a I
knew my five times five facts and one
times five facts I knew my nine plus
three fact a PI plus two fact and I also
had the understanding of place value to
pull it off right and that's the only
thing that can possibly replace when
you're counting is the combination of
these two things okay
we what we we call this alright and this
is probably what you're familiar with or
maybe you're not familiar with this term
what is the standard algorithm right
it's no longer am i counting upwards
right it's it's the it's this process
right I'm not counting by 38 672 times
all right but I have a an algorithmic
process okay
and it's this is the standard algorithm
for addition standard algorithm for
multiplication this is the standard
algorithm for division hopefully you are
all familiar with what I mean when I say
the standard algorithm okay now
okay if you've ever tried to teach
students this which I'm assuming all of
you have if you haven't but if you're
trying to teach student this the
difficult one of these right and when
you spend most of your time on is trying
to deal with this guy all right
trying to get kids to have an
understanding of place value that's a
really difficult difficult difficult
topic something we could do an entire
different session on okay it's not gonna
be this session about the place fire
your language and if you notice when I
did those problems I was pretty
intentional about using place value
language if you don't do that in your
teaching and maybe something you want to
think about trying to do but just be
very intentional with the kinds of place
value language that you do I'm not gonna
you guys are not gonna send me down the
rabbit hole place value because I will
talk to you and bore you and sleep make
you fall asleep about place value
forever right but today I want talk
about factual fluency and really the key
point that I want to make here is that
this needs to happen before this happens
okay and here's what I mean by that
here's why at least okay if you're a
student who your teacher is trying to
teach you the standard algorithm and you
don't know your facts you're gonna think
this standard algorithm is worse than
counting on your fingers because again
because of the problem that I have a
right and a reliable way to do this this
one I don't know my facts and therefore
this process here is not helpful to me
because I would rather add count up 23
to get to 82 then use the facts that
I've memorized okay so there way to make
the standard algorithm attractive to
students is to do it after they have an
understanding of their facts to say we
can take this whole process and break it
down into only facts that are between
zero and ten and we have all those facts
memorized
that's the real argument for the
standard algorithm is that it happens
very right
if you makes use of the facts that they
already know and takes a really
difficult problem and breaks it down
into just facts that we have memorized
sorry okay take a second do do a little
bit of a nerdy moment with me here right
and look at this this is a difficult
problem and we did it only without ever
dealing with a fact that was greater
than ten that's really cool actually
right that's pretty good okay math is
cool we broke down that crazy problem
into just that and this is one our kids
too met to realize why that's cool but
they're not gonna think it's cool unless
they actually know the facts that are
from zero to ten
yes so what has to happen is this has to
happen before this right so these need
to be switched right this is first first
factual fluency has to happen first okay
we need to get our kids to memorizing so
and let me give you a little bit of an
overview of where things happen okay so
most textbooks not all of them the
standard algorithm for addition and
subtraction happens at the very
beginning of second grade that's not
always true all right some some
textbooks it happens in first grade and
you probably do a little bit of it in
first grade anyways but most textbooks
at the very least have it at the
beginning of second grade which means
that by the end of your first grade year
you need to know all the math facts of
addition subtraction zero to ten and you
have to be fluent in them if you're
gonna really appreciate the standard
algorithm that starts in the beginning
of second grade it's a lot of pressure
on the kindergarten and first grade
teachers
to get their kids ready for that and
that if you've got if you guys can set
their your kids on that road that's
invaluable and that you guys know this
because you teach kindergarten every day
and first graders every day that's what
you've chosen to do with your with your
lives that it's a noble pursuit but
that's actually one of the reasons why
it's hugely noble and you can what you
do makes or breaks right what happens in
the upper grades and no one knows this
better than a fifth-grade teacher
I brought a fifth grade teacher along so
that so that she could nod at me and by
the time you go to the multiplication
and division algorithms that happen in
at the beginning of third grade to have
all your multiplication facts memorized
by the end of second grade that's a
difficult challenge I doubt there's too
many of us who are really making so as a
first grade teacher if you can get your
kids to have all your multiplication
instruction passed and rise behind at
first grade oh that should be just one
of your main goals of the year
second graders summary teachers just one
of your main goals can you grant
teachers you guys can play with shapes
or so no I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding
very much getting very much no no no you
guys know I love you you know I love
okay sorry
kidding kidding we're talking about
we're gonna talk about what
kindergarteners can do
I've hold it I thought I told myself I
was gonna make that joke and I made it
okay all right so Patrick Fulop Samson's
first okay so factual fluency actual
vote see yeah right factual fluency
right it's a it's a buzz word like what
do I mean what do you mean by factual
fluency mr. Greg this is just kind of
two random words that you stuck together
and they sound nice but how do we do
this right okay good so we're doing
actual fluency has also two parts
surprise breasts okay
perfectly yes two parts and it's one all
right this is under the section that's
titled
factual [ __ ] great okay perfect
drink so well does that line thing she
news for all my talks function [ __ ] has
two parts one it has obviously the
actual knowledge like you literally know
your facts okay
studies will not acknowledge go to
actual habituation okay so pretty easy
dichotomy here you have to both know
something and be in the habit of doing
it okay
think of anything that you know or do
let's pick parallel parking all right
how many of you know how to parallel
park but never parallel park and that
means you don't really know how to
parallel park
yeah right you have to both know how to
parallel park and do it in order to have
parallel parking fluency yes okay so
fashion Woolsey has has has two parts
right you have to have first let's talk
about factual knowledge there's a sec
right you have to have the facts at your
fingertips right but don't be where that
is this right when I say something to
you like I'll give you a fact three plus
four you don't have to think about that
to have seven pop into your mind I'm
saying all right you don't have to act
you know it's it's that that's what you
mean by the facts your fingertips that
you don't have to associate the example
that I started come up with an analogy
about this and I don't know there's
gonna be a good one but I'm gonna run
with it anyways
it's the difference between how I know
that Boise is the capital of Idaho and
how I know that my daughter's name is
Ellie okay
there's a difference there right I have
to think about the fact that boys's the
cap like some sense what's the capital
of Idaho
maybe after maybe maybe some of you know
that the cattle of Idaho is Boise and
like that's a
that you have at your fingertips so that
in which case this is a bad example but
for me that's something that I kind of
just think about that I know and I can
bet I can get there but that's not what
I mean by factual knowledge it's but the
fact that my daughter's name is Ellie
all right I don't even have I look at
her or you know what's your daughter's
name and I don't have to think about it
it's there right it's it's it's that
kind of knowledge that we want to
develop and write again the big question
floating around in the back like you
should have this floating around in the
back right now mr. Greg Howe please tell
us how to do this okay yeah I'm gonna
get their props right okay I promise but
that's the kind of knowledge that we
want to have so the they yes students
have to here nine plus five and not even
think nine plus five so much as they
just think 14 okay that's the kind of
fluency that we're looking for right and
then be factual situation right pretty
simple they have to use their facts when
they're actually doing math right the
things they do it during fact time
during the day and the things they do it
every math time during the day are not
two separate entities so how do you have
bitchu eight students to use their fax
in your classroom or a couple of the big
questions right so how do you get kids
to have the kind of factual knowledge
that we're looking for and how do you
get them to use it I kind of these are
the big I want to talk about both of
those how do you do do you pull this off
um any questions so far on any of the
like problem section any anyone
wondering about something specifically
so far that you're not gonna be able to
move on without getting that question
answered awesome
can't tell if it's a good thing or a bad
thing but I'm gonna keep going because
that's bad teaching but I'm just gonna
keep doing all right so my solution okay
and my solution you guessed it has two
parts
solution two parts and one of them is
and I don't really have this in the
outline oh yes I do oh yes I do so
there's one there's some activities
I put activities I don't really like the
word activities but I put it down there
anyways just stuff that you do not more
like do it is we're good so crest okay
not activities this is just stuff that
you'd in your classroom activity is
specifically specific specifically
designed for facts right and then
there's two there are sets of what did I
say what is on the back
Dale eat eating habits daily cheating
habits daily teachings habits okay so
what I'm hoping to lay out for you guys
is some practical things that you can do
to build your students mathematical
knowledge there's also I think an
underrated part here that just habits of
your classroom that are hard for me to
pin down except for just kind of give
you some advice on on how to do this
they're not specific things that you do
and say this is math back time but it's
just ways in which your classroom runs
I'm gonna nail down some daily teaching
habits that I hope will be helpful but
both of these things need to happen
right you have to do some specific
things for facts and you also have to
have some just habits that you do in
your classroom that matter as you guys
I'm sure most of you know this right but
as I as I watch more classrooms as I do
more and more teaching myself right it's
less the specific things that I'm doing
and more just the general way in which
my classroom runs the things that I
embody and model that end up making
big difference it's it's it's much more
the habits of my classroom than it is
the things that happen in my classroom
that matter that's why I included that
second section and I don't think this is
I think this is it's an underrated part
of often when we're trying to fix a
problem we look here right so we should
probably hear a lot more just so we'll
talk about those in just a sec so under
the activities I have them specially
specified again into two parts right
there's activities for learning new
facts and then there's did I say
practicing practicing old facts that
makes sense
some nice parallel structure if my wife
will be proud practicing some old facts
right so the difference between okay I
have a kid who does not know that two
plus three actually equals five all
right or nine plus eight equals or six
times seven equals right that's this
first part and then the second one is
okay my kids know the two plus three
equals five but they don't have real
factual knowledge and I need to get them
to prep I did to practice it over and
over and over with them how are some
ways to practice facts or they just
learned three plus four I want to
incorporate that into all of their other
facts as well right so some ways to
learn new facts and some ways to
practice old facts okay so learning new
facts and I want to actually actually
pose this question to you
the thing about the difference between
how I know that Boise is the capital of
the Idaho and how I know that my
daughter's name is Ellie okay I think
what matters is how I learned that fact
matters how we learned it okay so
someone give me some answers maybe about
think about your own daughter obviously
right you don't know my you know my
daughter at all right hopefully
no you don't know my daughter at all
that but talking about what the
difference is between how you learn that
Boise is the capital of Idaho and how
you learned that maybe just think about
this one
how did you come how did I come to learn
that my daughter's name is Ellie yeah
okay yeah absolutely definitely
something that that's not the case for
Boise Idaho for me at least okay I
actually named her right yeah no that's
well I wife did but I kind of named her
I was there seen a lot yeah rip I repeat
it yeah very good very good
what else it's exactly right I've got
some memories that are associated with
it yeah absolutely
yeah just one yeah okay yeah no that's
fair I will probably it's a good point
yeah but but I place some kind of
special emphasis on it right yeah
absolutely
good I came up with I came up with seven
things that are the way that I learned
how to do it and most of them are
actually on this page so you can turn
there okay so I cope with seven
different ways so this is under learning
new facts on the first page of your
thing okay take notes plenty new ways I
go with seven ways one alright there's
some kind of a tangible some kind of a
tangible encounter with her right so for
Ellie this was I have physically met and
interacted with her right that I didn't
I've never been to Boise Idaho I don't
have any physical tangible encounter
with Boise Idaho I don't have anything
associated with Boise out of you in mind
so under under the
all right some kind of uh I'm I need to
build it I need to actually have an
encounter with something physical that
puts that physical thing in my mind and
in my experience all right some kind of
a physical encounter it's not just five
plus nurse okay or six times four so
just that six times four is floating in
this abstract here right but I literally
have something in my mind that I can
count I have six and four right and what
did I would I have a picture of there
yeah I've got some I've got some egg
cartons right
I think curtains yes what's more like
twelve times two to me but maybe you
have half egg curtains right yeah you
have four half egg curtains that's what
I have have that's not a half okay so
for F egg cartons right or 640 flowers
right some kind of a physical encounter
with your fact okay some kind of a
building of it okay - one of the things
that I can do with Elly
besides the tangible encounter visually
the age of isère and s2a thoughts s
deathly mess visualization with it s yes
when I close my eyes I can think of
Ellie I can picture her and picture her
alright if I close my eyes I cannot
picture Boise Idaho
there's no visualization of it oh right
yeah dry all right some kind of a way of
visualizing of drawing of converting it
this is the Singapore is this the
Singapore model right this is the one
thing you guys know about Singapore math
there's the pictorial right is the one
thing that we all know about so you okay
good we don't know anything you also
think before we know it's about pictures
okay good visualization good all right
three
I spent time comparing and contrasting
le right what ways does she look like my
wife and what ways that she look like me
all right
what are your fingers are bigger now
right spend time discussing comparing it
to other things right
pairing and contrasting it for I discuss
her a contextualise her I observe for a
continuously having her be part of the
things that I do on a daily basis I'm
willing to talk about her right if you
if you ask me to show you picture of her
yeah I will talk to you about I mean I
could talk for a long time about this
right I discuss her and texturizer v
yeah I find her beautiful in some way
shape or form right it's part of the
reason why I'm right I remember is and
that's not the trooper Boise Idaho right
maybe it is for some of you right but I
find her beautiful some way I and I
think what's on here right is oh this
one is uh yeah sorry this is fine yeah
appreciate it finds okay right I mean
looking for her looking to observe her
right or appreciating I'm finding some
way to find it beautiful or interesting
or meaningful I guess I think I have
that beautiful interesting
meaningful and then as some of you guys
said they may be this missus cows over
there all right all right yeah
I repeat it over and over and over again
over and over and over Jana
I see her everyday I just call her by
name every day right Pete it was it oh
yeah no I really should have brought
that as a PowerPoint slide she's so cute
oh my god she's seven months so she's
got she has her first tooth in today so
it's just pretty it's pretty happy
there's a seventh one on here that I'm
gonna come to so leave a little bit of
room on the bottom your page for a
seventh one I think there's a seven one
that matters but it's okay so how do we
you how do I take this stuff about my
daughter and transition it into the math
classroom right one of the things that I
proposed is some kind of and when you're
learning a new fact is to try to learn
it on a bunch of different levels right
I'm proposing and you may want to take
this I've had some really good success
with it in my classrooms but some kind
of the fact of the week okay and what
this is this might be a picture of my
whiteboard or a corner of my whiteboard
over the course of a week so picture
this in the corner of your whiteboard
now you got your fact of the week up top
you find some way to build it to
tangibly encounter it all right maybe
you thought you can find some four-leaf
clovers but for multiplication by three
you could put three leaf clovers maybe
not some of you don't live by clover
fields but you bunch of three leaf
clovers and bring them in from
altercation by three but finding some
way to build it finding someone to get
your kids to tangibly encounter it all
right
stick some magnets in the back of those
clovers and stick them up on your
whiteboard you don't have magnet tape in
your classroom magnet tape is literally
the best invention for teachers ever she
gets a magnet it's like two bucks build
it find some way to get all your kids
building that fact okay
draw it dry right and you could do this
you can do one of these every day you
have a whole week to do a fact one of
these every day
you build it one day its extensive or
this takes you to MIT platitudes five
minutes in your classroom high dry I use
mustaches cuz I think much those are fun
most of your kids but I think most those
are fun too but you can use whatever you
want to try right what should we use
this week to dry kids right and draw the
fact everyone get that out your own
whiteboards and draw it find some way to
draw it counter it on that level and
every time you say close your eyes
remember what we drew our what we drew
what did we draw for this one they're
really struggling with six times four
this was the mustache fact already it's
starting to get ingrained habituated
into their heads little section right
here compare and contrast it right take
a day and say what facts do we know that
our close to it
well facts do we know that our have the
same answer have an answer that's really
close to it all right now you're
actually getting into the realm of some
number sense which whoa hold on we can't
get our kids to vote no yes you can
right number sense number sense right
she says four is the same as six as far
as close to you all right compare and
contrast it's been a day comparing
contrasting find it find it's a really
fun one it doesn't have to be done every
day but over the course of the week you
find it in some of the problems that
you're doing right I found these are
probably not problems that you guys
would be doing but I found six times
four and a bunch of problems all right I
circled them with yellow looks kind of
weird but anyways I tried I circled over
the yellow right and you can find it
keep track of all the times that you
find it make a challenge right get tell
your kids to clip up if they can find
the fact of the week in any of their
math problems all right if you can find
it back to the week somewhere Oh mister
we found a week you know you can think
it's so psyched about this kind of stuff
find it
appreciate it find some way and make it
meaningful I was looking for six times
four facts there's not really that many
good ones the one that cool one that I
found was industrial sized muffin tins
like I really love muffins and so I like
you can ask my wife like really like
muffins I didn't know industrialists
they made six by four muffin tins but
now that I do and I think I have to get
one I know if it'll fit in my oven but
that's cool that for me right and now I
remember six cents for you know finding
some one way to do that right or a
standard photograph right it is a six by
four photograph then repeat it right
repeat it probably being the now I'm
getting a little bit more into daily
teaching habits right but think about
the way that you do all your rigs things
and I'm not a rich text for so please
don't ask me any questions on rigs but
one thing I've heard them talk about is
something called punctuated practice
right what happens over the course of
the day right math facts the fact of the
week can be something you can punctuated
practice right and sneak attack the kids
right be like I was just you know you're
in really your science lesson science
lesson you're like oh yeah I was just
thinking about what stick sense for it
and for you know and you know but this
kind of like repeat it and then every
you'd make a little mark on the bottom
of your board where you oh we did I we
practiced our fact right we had six
times four we repeated it over and over
and over again and so at the bottom your
board maybe you have a little Italian
mark you know this kind of punctuated
practice if you take a fact of the week
you do that with it think your kids are
gonna remember it you think you're gonna
have some things to draw on when you're
talking about it and when your kids
struggle with it remember what kind of
what fact that was what do we have up
there for I we built it with what we
have up there that we're gonna draw it
drew it flip your packets to this guy
it's probably little bit more
information than you wanted here and
it's not the only way to do it but you
could potentially do a fact of the week
for all most
almost every fact could be a fact of the
week all right
I don't have one plus one on here or one
plus two but I don't think you really
need a fact of the week on one plus one
and probably not okay but over the
course of first grade you can cover all
of it you can if you've a week on all
your addition facts get all of them you
can spend a week on them here's one
suggested schedule so what I have here
is the kinds of facts that you should be
working on so kindergarten and I'll
address this down in just a sec because
it's not actually none but it's let me
come back to that
please I know that some of you can do
our teachers are frowny I mean like what
do we think we do in the first half of
kindergarten right no I'm not I don't
think there's none there right but I'm
sorry you're just glare yeah excuse of
death stares from the kindergarten
teachers I apologize okay so the way you
read this right the top little bar is
the kinds of facts you should be working
on right so plus or minus 210 that's
everything from zero plus zero to five
plus five okay
review plus or minus 220 right that's
everything from zero zero to 10 plus 10
and 20 minus 10 right all the way right
and then for multiplication and things
like division of things that I just did
your the the twos or threes the four out
the fives etc right okay so and you can
see it's a pretty you can look through
the third through sixth grade section
it's a little bit crazier there right
but under this you've got a fact of the
week and so there's four facts
underneath there you have four weeks in
a in a month right you could potentially
you do all of those facts of the week
and still hit almost every single fact
if you just did one a week you think is
that definite is that enough to cover
all the things no if you one o fact a
week
you can still cover all the things you
need to cover and if you're doing in
fact a week if you're learning it if
you're internalizing it now you're
actually you're taking you're taking
five minutes a day you got your math
facts memorized when you're supposed to
let me talk about the first two have a
kindergarten the reason why I don't have
anything there is because you don't ever
get the addition process something you
do not don't know facts or aren't using
numbers and figure out relationships in
numbers but you don't actually get the
addition symbol until halfway through
kindergarten and the textbook at least
some of you I'm sure do they might do it
at a different time so that's why I
don't have anything there not to say you
couldn't do a fact of the week and you
could do like the 1 plus 1 is the 1 plus
2 is things like that if you wanted to
use in your kindergarten class but you
don't have to but I think the second
half of kindergarten like really mean
you got to start to in facts practice
then you could do effect of the weekend
kindergarten and that would be really
really wonderful I think if you if you
want to extend it backwards into the
first half of kindergarten I have no
problem with that
but all this schedule was was just to
say even if you don't have anything in
first time Kinnaird and he only did one
fact a week you can still do it right
one fact a week learn it in the same way
that we learn the things that we want to
remember we learned them this way we
don't learn them by reading them out of
a book we don't learn them we learn them
by being intentional about finding
meaningful ways to encounter them I
don't have to do something like this on
your board but if I was trying to teach
something someone something new a fact
is what I would do
put it on my board just you need one
section of your board put some tape
write some stuff in permanent don't
write some stuff in permanent right so
right build it in permanent ink up there
so you said up to your race you don't
need something like this for learning
new facts so what I would do if your
kids are behind
they don't you're a secondary teacher
and they don't know any their addition
facts you can back up the process you
can back it up okay
it's the same kind of a process for
learning whatever fact you want but it's
just one potential schedule that you
might know if you're a school leader it
might be something you share with your
staff know say here's a potential
schedule that you could you're
responsible for these facts if you're uh
if you're a first grade teacher you'd be
like all right I'm gonna go talk to the
kindergarten teachers at my school make
sure they're doing or I'm gonna talk to
the second great you know whatever okay
cool you guys you guys know about that
kind of stuff any questions about
learning new facts yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think that's those are gonna be more
it's actually going to be closer to the
data more more more the kind of habits
that you do in the classroom or I think
yeah yeah no I think those are more yeah
I think these are gonna be I'm gonna get
to those kind of things a little bit
closer to here this is I'm just talking
about if you have a brand new fact
treating it as a fact something that you
want to memorize but I think those are
great teaching have I mean yeah that's
exactly right but this is just one way
that you could learn new facts yeah good
question any other questions about maybe
some ways in which you could teach your
kids a new fact that's what I would do
all right practicing old facts okay I
would spend how were you would spend ten
to fifteen minutes every day practicing
old facts okay ten to fifteen minutes
every day practicing old facts you can
do it at the beginning your math lesson
at the end of your math lesson my
favorite thing to do is to not do it at
all around your math lesson and do it
sometime in the afternoon when the kids
are a little bit weird
and squirrely okay so you can focus your
math time on your math lesson but you
still have whoops you still have ten
minutes in the afternoon yeah
you got a weird 15 minute block in your
schedule make that your math facts time
okay so practicing old facts what I
would do if I were you
so hey there's a couple bad things that
happen when we're trying to practice
facts one is we do the same thing every
single day to do it okay kids get bored
and it's not as effective as if you were
trying to do five or six different
things okay same thing every day so this
happens most often with either speed
tests or flashcards
all right and you know and flashcards
are easy just hold them up but get
everything flush car they're easy speed
tests are pretty easy you print it off
you give it to the kids you have two
minutes of silence where they're right
and I think they're both really good
things PDFs and flashcards are part of
part of the curriculum that I'd
recommend they're both very good things
but I would not recommend doing them
every single day a couple reasons one
kids get a little bit bored of them even
if they say they love their speed tests
maybe a little bit bored too it really
only works their brains in one way all
right only works through brains in one
way whereas if you're doing five or six
different things you're working their
brains in a variety of different ways
you're getting them to think differently
about something right so if you're if
you've only been practicing your math
facts in one way challenge yourself to
branch out branch out a little bit what
I've done is I've got five things that I
would do okay I would do if I were you
you don't do this you can take it this
is one of the things you can take a
little piece and go with it five things
I would do one of these every single day
so Monday is our speed test day right
Tuesdays are whatever right no don't
read it out all right but I'm gonna give
you the actual schedule but like the
this is again so all I'm trying to do is
so it preserves some of the things that
you like about something that happens
every day right everyone knows this is
speed test day there's a speed test
there's order there's structure the kids
can follow it right if you're doing the
same thing on every Monday the kids are
gonna it might take them a little bit
longer to habitual to it right but they
know what to expect and they can follow
the set structure right just one of the
reasons why you like doing the same
thing every day
so same thing every Monday send me over
to them is every Wednesday Thursday
Friday you can expect this you can get
in the habit of it as a teacher you
don't want to be constructing something
new every day right you don't have time
for that you don't you got you've lives
right you have other things to do but if
you're doing the same thing every day
and you have five things you teach your
kids you're getting the kids to to get
some variety in their in their day so
this is what I would do there's five
things that I do number one is what I do
on Monday this is my Monday game where
am I can I fit these here probably have
to yeah oh wait I have a seven oh ok so
Monday I call this game plus minus plus
minus you can probably think of a better
game than this better name for it than
this but I call it plus minus plus minus
my kids absolutely absolutely love this
game this is their favorite game I do it
on Monday I don't know why it's their
favorite game I actually saw some
teachers in think playing this maybe
Sophie from Louisville nice think
they're playing this ok but it goes like
this and I've actually got a piece of
paper in here so turn maybe to this
there's a page says plus bias or some
examples ok and what happens is they
have a whiteboard ok or something to
write on it can be a piece of paper
doesn't really matter if you have
whiteboards the best though okay and you
say something like start with one add
one add 2 subtract one answer
okay right good it's written there it's
written there so those of you who did
nicely done but it's also written there
okay and you can start really slow what
you don't want them to do is this on
their white board you want them doing
this and you want them kind of doing
something
did I say plus 100 hold on one plus one
was to this sounds like a really dopey
game it's only a really dopey game the
kids they well what happens you start
really slow so what you want them to see
on the paper is 1 and then plus 1 plus 2
minus 1 you want to see them writing not
this so much as this where they're doing
the facts in their head there's a subtle
difference between this and this but
this is what you want to see okay you
can start really slow but then you
always want to start speeding up with
speedy gap in the kit and then you you
know you finished with 1 like 1 plus 1
minus 2 well sorry okay and you're none
of them couldn't follow it right but
it's always you you always get them
going but they what what if this game is
doing for them right it's doing a lot of
facts in conjunction with each other
right you can see on this piece of paper
alright this is you know maybe if you're
a kindergarten teacher you're doing
facts that are along the first two lines
but this game can be played all the way
up to eighth grade all right and even
longer some of those ones that that the
interesting ones and the last little few
lines there right some of you might have
trouble with these if I were to actually
do these woods and require to do this
kind of mental math right but this game
is really really flexible and the kids
they love this game but it's doing a lot
of their facts you know and have them
keep score on their own on their own
whiteboard if this is their whiteboard
you know if you get it right give
yourself a point and then see how many
points they get at the end right you
don't need to make it a huge game but
it's a really good way of just getting
that it's easy there's no materials
required it's not a very big thing but
you're working on the facts
notice right you can always incorporate
the fact of the week into these games
and kids can find the fact of the week
right and the kid is like that was the
fact of the week we're excited you know
you could get the fact of the week into
this game really easily right I found it
mr. Greg you know the there's no end to
the kind of complexity and speed that
you can do you can vary it alright for
kindergarteners you as you just
interesting you can go really really
slow but buddy just like a grade you can
do I mean you can go pretty quick with
this kind of things you know you can ask
good questions at the end
that's saying things like why was that
one so difficult what was the hardest
part
what was the which one did we really
struggle with that's kind of things plus
minus plus minus really really easy game
really really good for math facts I
would do that I'm on this any questions
I'm plus minus plus minus very easy
obviously you can mix in some additions
multiplications and division if you want
to you can call something else yeah
yeah I I really want I think so a couple
answers
hey I think if you think if you ever
asked me uh do you think they should
draw it I'm gonna say yes right but
actually I think more no for this game
just because they're working on mental
math facts right I don't want them to
have to draw the answer to get these
right all right so I'm gonna say no
although in general I want to encourage
drawing is that an okay answer okay yeah
I would say no but you want is to see
something like this or even better yet
if they can do without writing anything
on the whiteboard that could be you make
that worth double points and I've never
done that by that it would be a good
rule okay cool
any other questions I + - lets - very
easy game super good - on Tuesday
Tuesday's are my least favorite days as
a teacher so we play my favorite game
Tuesdays this target war okay so you can
flip to the page look at the page that
has target will on it for
kindergarteners I play this game with
dice just because so that restricts you
to numbers up through six every other
grade I play this with playing cards
okay which are really cheap every kid
has a deck of playing cards I take out
the jacks and the kings throw them away
don't even give it to him the Queen's
are zeros just the Q kind looks like a
zero and then you have just 0 through 10
cards all right great easy way right and
so target war again there are no no ends
to the complexities you can throw into
this game but it can also be played very
simple I hope you guys know how to play
regular war right you turn over a card
your point turns over a card and the
highest
Wynn's okay the there was a between
target war is you give them a target
okay so normally if I turn over an eight
mister dubrovnik turned over a two I
would win but if we're playing target
war with a target of three mister
dubrovnik would win because he is closer
to three okay so it's not just because
kids don't really do any math facts when
it's when you're talking about just
which one's higher like that's not
really a good game but if you give them
a target now they actually have to start
comparing numbers developing numbers
sense so when I play with target war
each person flips over two cards I
should have brought my deck of cards
what was I thinking
couple different ways you can do it you
can play gruberman partners and have
them play against the person next to
them or they can play against you and
you can put one on the document camera
and then they're playing it individually
so if you turn over
let me see clean a game first and then
we can go let's do that so so right you
want to roll two dice or flip over two
cards you don't just look over one and
regular while you're jumping over to
okay and you're giving them an operation
and it's hard yet alright and you think
that kindergartners can't quite handle
this but they can handle it especially
by the enter kindergarten definitely can
handle target war flip over to so
there's an example here look at the
first example my addition my operation
is addition okay and my target is six
okay so one person rolled a four and a
five the third person rolled a three and
a one okay 4 + 5 is 9 which is 3 away
from 6 & 1 & 3 & 4 is 4 which is 2 away
from 6 so the person who would win would
be the person who rolled the 1 and the 3
they would give themselves a point
and you'd play the next round
okay what you really want to do is get
your kids talking and or saying it out
loud right and say four or five is nine
which is three way from six so they're
not just kind of that they're the ones
doing their facts and the saying it of
it is good you have to make sure they
say it in not really loud voices so that
you don't want to kill yourself but the
so then they would give it one person to
give themselves a point and they'd roll
again if we look at the second example
right I've got cards got a tart a day an
addition a target of 10 3 9 is 12 which
is 2 away 4 and 0 is 4 which is 6 away
the person you had the 3 and the 9 would
win so you're doing but one thing I want
you to notice and I'll gift that
question is a sack right I want you to
notice how many facts you have to do in
order to play this game once right think
about it I've got to both know my 3 plus
9 fact right I've also got to know my 12
minus 10 fact just too and I've also got
to make a comparison between mine and
the other person's right I'd have to
know that 2 is less than 4 and that I am
the winner right and so they're doing
these facts right now you've got kids
that are doing multi-step problems
there's some of the hardest things ever
to teach kids just to play the game
right they're doing 3 facts and constant
in combination with each other question
okay yeah yeah and this is back to your
question right sometimes you can have
them play just with the person next to
them or I like to just play where I'll
turn over to cards I'm under the
document camera and the altar number
ones individually at their seats and
you'll see if you can beat the teacher
all right see how many points you score
against against the teacher and you know
then you can have one winner of over the
whole class who like I scored ten points
against the teacher right and so it also
keeps the chaos a little bit less right
we play a lot of beat the teacher in my
classrooms just be the teacher is yeah
you play against me instead of playing
us each other it's ends up being a
little bit chaotic a few but sometimes
they can handle it and sometimes not so
again there's no end the complexity of
this game right look at this last one
right you can multiply the greater two
and subtract the smallest one with the
target of 32 right I mean so this is
another really good way if you've got
some really advanced students mess with
them right say all right you guys you're
no longer playing with two cards you
deploy three right and even something
like that can challenge you're really
good students right as you're going
around and if they're playing mean
partners it's a great way you can
differentiate in your classroom just
with the game right without having to
mess with some of the kids who really
need to play with just to dice the tarts
so target Wars is is my Tuesday game
mainly because I hate Tuesdays because
they always seem the worst great yes
yeah so the first time you play it and
the first couple times you play it it's
gonna have to be you're a whole math
class to do it right because they've got
to learn it and they've got to practice
it but after they know how to do it
I can just say operation is addition
your target is eight go right
and that can be I'd say about 10 to 15
minutes not super long but just enough
to get some points on some points going
it's another good thing to do if you've
got kids that are finished early with
their worksheets all right you got two
of them say go sit quietly in the corner
and play target war great thing to do
with your kids that I've done early
they know how to play the game on their
practice their math facts in the corner
oh yeah yeah no yeah they do you don't
get to just rush through it so you can
plan again no no that's a good point
all right Wednesday
how do flashcards on Wednesday and if
you just I do them whole class
flashcards what I'll do is on and you
can I'm sure you all have different ways
that you think you're gonna do
flashcards but I'll just hold one up and
I'll call out a certain type of person
like boys and all the boys have to give
the answer or people with glasses or
people whose last name started with H
and and they have to call it the answer
so they always they're kind of you know
figuring out who's going either you guys
can do whatever you want for flashcards
but finding some way just to get
flashcards one of the best ways to just
get a lot of repetition real quick lots
of repetition real quick thoughts
repetition I do flashcards on Wednesdays
you can cope with a game for flashcards
if you want but I just mainly just kind
of flash some cards around
Thursday yeah I do speed test on
Thursday we keep some I mean a lot of us
have systems I'm sure for keeping track
of who's doing well on their speed tests
there's a lot of good speed test
generators online if you haven't found
them yeah my favorite website for this
is its Web math minute com
you can tell it exactly what kinds of
facts you want and how you can you can
do a lot of different kinds of things
you can do just addition - subtraction
basically you can generate however many
questions you want in whatever order you
want them lots of flexibility there and
then just print them out and print them
out speed tests are great and I'm sure
you guys know how to do speed tests last
will last game Friday I'm sure you guys
can think of a better name for this but
I play find a number that and you can
turn to the last page of your your
packet here for some examples this is
less math facts so much as working on
kids number sense since they're there
their creativity right but find a number
that something and give them some
specifics okay it can be as simple as
that's five less than seven right really
this is okay or you can see a bunch of
examples right I've included a ton of
them again there's a lot of complexity
you can mix this up this is a you know
if you were to implement this throughout
your whole school and kids do the same
thing for K through six like you know no
no they would just me they would know
what to expect on every Friday for there
all right you know you'd have some
consistency throughout from from year to
year from class to class right but
anyways right because you could play
this in sixth graders right and it gets
really fun I play this with my 12th
graders I play it differently and I call
it a different game but yeah I play I
play a it's a game called crypto and I
give them six numbers and they have to
make the first five numbers equal that
last one there's some kind of operation
so I would do something like like that
right all right 11 plus 1 raised to the
19th power is still 1 11 plus 1/12 all
right yeah all right but but my 12th
graders are really good at thank you and
there's nothing that there's right but
the roots of that game are in this game
right is is it's it's number sense it's
finding what is the number how do
numbers relate to each other what's the
number that's 5 less than 7 right some
of the good ones are the ones that are
the good ones that vary right 17 and 18
are really good find two numbers that
add together to get 11 right or even
find two sets of two numbers that add
together to get six right all sorts of
creative questions you can get your kids
thinking about and again you can just
plays with the whiteboard and marker all
right just say hold of your boards all
right find a number that's five less
than seven hold your boards if you got
it right give yourself a point really
easy game Friday so you don't really
want a particularly complex game so much
as you just want right there ready to
think creatively and do something
interesting so you can get this is some
this is a really good game to push the
limits of their understanding right so
if you've only done numbers through ten
all right and you're thinking find a
number that's four greater than seven
right
really pushes their their understanding
here right if you'd only done them if
you only done positive numbers right
this is more for like a fifth or sixth
grade one find a number that's six less
than
you like really messes with them yet at
this is for like the last question or
two right of the game where you really
want to challenge them some things like
this you can you can really yeah it's a
great point right find the sum of eight
and three right you can reinforce the
vocabulary where it's a great point yeah
so that's what I would do
just five different kinds of things
working on the same set of math packs
I would do spend ten to fifteen minutes
in your classroom these are my favourite
games and kids get excited about not
having to do the same thing every day
and it's thinking about them in
different ways one thing that's really
important to do and this is a good segue
into my last set of thoughts all right
some teaching habits good segue is when
you're done with the game make it a
point to ask a question about what just
happened okay
it's an important point what I mean by
that is this right ask a question like
which are the facts today was the
hardest for you how can we remember that
one which one was the easiest one my
favorite question to ask especially the
kindergarten first second graders is
what was your strategy for that game
like there is no strategy whatsoever in
target war none whatsoever but every kid
has a strategy and like I do this mr.
Greg okay
I'd there's no strategy for this game
whatsoever but all of them want to
explain to you the way they think about
it right and it's so good for them to
think about that those kind of things
right they all want to do that ask him a
question like that ask him did you see
our fact of the week anywhere right or
even just you know how did you figure
that one out how did you figure that one
out is a really good question just to
say you know this was that was a tough
one how did you figure it out
or what are you gonna do different next
time we play the game alright questions
like that
just one question at the end of the game
just to give them a habit of thinking
about the strategies thinking about the
facts which one was the hardest
six times four oh let's remember that
one next time or I think that's gonna be
the fact of the week next week or
whatever okay daily teaching habits my
last section hopefully is that right so
anything else on my outline oh yeah oh
yeah good good good
seven is actually the first daily
teaching habit good so daily GT habits
and I'm out of space with my board I'm
erasing this problem because we're
solving it just some things to
incorporate into your daily teaching
habit yeah so number one and that's
actually this here one of the other
reasons how I know that my daughter's
name is Ellie all right I expect it all
right if I forgot my daughter's name do
you think my wife would be upset at me
yeah probably
ya know expect it all right once you
have the knowledge like this right I
don't expect you guys to know that boys
is the capital of Idaho all right we're
gonna do trivia tonight I'm not gonna
expect you guys to know the answers to
the questions that I'm gonna ask but I
expect you to know two plus three right
and once we have a fact in the week I
expect my students to know that all
right so daily teaching habits expect
what did I say something
expect your students to use them so this
is the difficult part of teaching okay
that means that when you see your
students counting on their fingers for a
fact that you know that they're supposed
to know you've got to tell them to stop
you don't to be a jerk about it all
right but saying something like we know
this one this is one of our facts of the
week can you think of that one in your
mind right we're second graders now we
know that one we don't need to account
for that one on our fingers we know that
one that was one of our facts of the
week right that was something that we
know right find a way to expect it of
your students all right fine
if students know that their teacher is
going to make them use their facts
they're gonna use their facts all right
if they know they can get away with
counting on their fingers I'm an easy
thing as a teacher right you got so many
things that you're trying to do and
trying to keep track of all right he's
counting us fingers all right let them
count his fingers right I'm trying to
deal with that right now
be intentional about expecting it expect
it you don't to be you don't to go crazy
about it and hold them too ridiculously
high expectations right and it's a
process to get them to stop counting on
their fingers right to work with them to
do it but you also have to hold them to
some expectations expect it do
work some facts into your lesson plans
on my lesson plan sheet I have a box
right this just says facts whenever I
think of a moment during the class where
I think oh I'm gonna stop here and we're
gonna talk about the facts that we know
that's what I write in that box
find some way to make an intentional
part about you what you're doing right
highlight the fact of the week figure
out if there's good ways to remember the
fact right stop and appreciate that we
know that fact right you have to point
is you have to make it a priority for
yourself if you're gonna make it a
priority for your students okay got to
make it a party for yourself the best
way to do it corporate into your lesson
plans three get excited about your facts
right
this is the easy one to do as a teacher
or at least it should be right get
excited about when you see your Fagin
the way get if if right especially
kidding here in the first and second
graders right they respond they get
excited about what their teachers get
excited about right if you are a teacher
who likes the math facts right your kids
are also gonna do that right if your
kids here doesn't really care it's not
gonna care get excited about them right
facts are useful they help us right if
facts find a way so you get excited
about we know this fact this is it makes
this problem so easy we know this one
already right the best best problem in
the world should be this one this is the
best one something like this this is
great 11 plus 11 it's great right we
don't need to know anything else but one
this one is too that's so great we're
gonna count from 11 up to 22 great fact
stop and appreciate it say we only
needed to use one fact it was
okay cool get excited I need some more
water look for patterns look for tricks
look for songs to remember them right
I'm not usually a fan of songs too much
but songs to memorize facts rhymes like
I still know six times eight I used to
hate but now I know it's 48 right that's
that's how I learned that one I still
remember that one whatever it is right
that's right
find some facts you just want the kids
to memorize them to internalize them
find some ways to get to to emphasize
them they're interesting they're not
boring fact I'm it's not boring time
it's fun and you know but the fact of
the week stuff on the board or talk
about one a little bit sneak attack them
right or or punctuated practice right
facts are something that take three
seconds in the middle of middle of a day
right one teacher I saw this this was
really cool you know I don't know if you
all have something that you do like one
two three and all you students say like
eyes on me or something like that
instead of doing that she would yell at
a math fact as soon as they have to say
the answer and she'd both command their
attention and like she'd yelled the math
back to the week and right no someone
wasn't paying attention with her math
back to the way guy could there be
punishment you know but right instead of
just doing one two three she would give
something something like that right but
punctuated practice some gutsy Kotak
them right in the middle of your sized
lesson math fact all right okay cool
five
yeah talk about the strategies okay we
talked about this a little bit with the
games okay the best question is best
question here something like this how
did you figure it out or how can we
figure it out right some kind of talking
about the strategies six times four is
six double doubled sit right finding
some kind of talking about the
strategies talk about how we can
remember it not just not just expecting
to remember it but giving them some ways
in which they can remember it okay talk
about it lastly really good one for
kindergarten first and second grade
assign um write kindergarteners and
first graders especially they don't need
to be going home with worksheets every
day but they do need to be going home
something to do at home and if it's
teach your parents target war and play
that for 10 minutes
that is the best homework assignment you
can possibly give to a first grader oh
that's so good all right assign it you
don't want to be great it saves you on
grading you don't be grading their
worksheets every day second graders
you're starting to get in the in the
place where maybe you can send home a
worksheet now and then and that's a good
thing for them to start doing right or a
page from the workbook or something like
that every now and then for second
graders but still assign them how can go
home and do the flashcard with their
parents or how can go home and play and
play target war with their with their
brother right this is the best you know
if you want to make an assignment right
you can whip up a page that has their
parents initial five times that they did
it right and you want to make it for a
grade and they you give them one on
Friday and they
Monday and they bring in next Monday
they're like I played this game every
night with my parents right you can make
new grades for it right if your homework
assignments but use their homework to
Hunter practice their facts parents love
that kind of stuff
most parents do some parents know some
parents don't a lot of parents do that a
lot of parents love that stuff
assign them have a contest to see how
many times you could they can say the
fact between leaving school and coming
back home back the next morning see how
many one of them gets to it's a funnel
hey and I'll end with this I know I'd
completely blew through my question time
but just lastly it creative all right
lots of different wings that I haven't
listed here you can get creative about
finding ways to get your kids to
memorize their math facts but that's got
to be a goal for if we're ever gonna
forever gonna get I erased it right
where we're gonna develop some factual
fluency it's got to be intentionally
done I'm out of time and you guys are
tired and you need your leisure
activities to get to please if you have
any questions come talk to me or send me
an email or like just you know you don't
use all this stuff but just there's some
stuff have a good afternoon off
you